okay i guess i'll play a track slayer if
my point goes into it
never mind okay we have an english
there's a few things i can play against
english i usually play e6 or e5
maybe i'll play e5 but i'll play a more
like standard line
i sometimes like to play reverse grand
prix
maybe i'll just go into the the two
knights
oh my my layout sorry about that
okay we should be back to normal now
i did have a book on the english when i
was younger
um was by karpov
it was a white i think it was a white
repertoire or like white
perspective but i remember he had a
whole section on this
like these lines where
like there's a few ways of playing we're
showing some setup like a6 bishop a7
d6 h6 castling and
just getting kind of reverse sort of
close sicilian
e4 oh so e4 is a um
the so-called baffnec about v-neck
the drawback of e4 is my bishop's now
happy
targeting f2 and d4 is a bit of a
weakness because these pawns can't move
backwards
okay so i can't really play knight g4
or bishop g4 i'll play bishop e6 hitting
the pawn
i have a feeling white's gonna have some
issues here
because h3 was played so early i can
play queen d7 create the battery
and it might be hard for like to castle
king side
do i have an undercover account for
online chess
all the games i play pretty much are
public on
either this account or trust.com i go
by i am rosen it could be nice to have
like an undercover account though
someday play maybe this move
hey it's adfoss ooh gifting five more
subs
further incentivizing me to play a
traxler
if i have a secret account oh i would
admit it on stream
actually i do have a somewhat secret
account but i don't use it to play
it's just an account that can go into if
i need to like make a secret study or
something
so i guess i did admit it on stream kind
of
i don't really have much to hide from
people
it's actually a good move knight d5
i think i'm okay allowing the trade and
just getting double pawns and
later going for f5 i can do this
giving away the taste of their own
medicine
very crowded center right now
i have a actually another account only
chess it's my blind account it's blind
eric
which i haven't played on in a long time
[Music]
i have gone through phases though where
i'll play on that account off stream
like if i'm tired and want to play chess
but don't want to stream my eyes i'll
just
like wear a blindfold and type my moves
a lot of tension in the center that's
one of these like english positions it's
hard to
get much of a clear edge
this hangs with bishop
doesn't work because my bishop gets
trapped i could take the knight
but then takes okay i'm considering c6
which could provoke takes takes
takes takes even bishop takes
yeah i might actually want to take with
bishop here
let's assume i don't know
what white takes back with actually
this
then i can play bishop b4 okay let's go
for this
so i'm giving up my potential for the
battery and probably allowing white to
castle very soon
at the same time i get some initiative
white will have to have to make a
committal decision how to
define the pawn structure
oh logicate saw my yeah my
recent video is my first uh streamed
stafford gambit
it was a fun one to look back on
the video already existed on youtube but
it was from a stream
almost three years ago had to repurpose
into its own video
yeah people are welcome to
to look back at my older videos because
a lot of my early content were just full
streams
like hour plus long streams that
probably have some hidden gems
and now my my youtube channel allows for
people to make clips
so there's like hidden gems that people
find you can make a clip of it
and send it to me or post it in discord
where did i learn the staff right now i
think i first
learned about the stafford from watching
a chess talk video
it's one of the largest chess youtube
channels
does a lot of like opening trap content
but only post like maybe a video every
few weeks or a video a month
at least used to and
did have a video of like the basic traps
in stafford
but then i remember seeing that video
looking into the opening and then just
discovering
so many more traps but that was the
early beginning
i take okay so these are the two
candidate moves
i don't think there's really anything
else to
consider so closely
so it takes takes i can take on g3 in
that line
yeah let's go for this because white
probably has to take with queen
and then
positions probably roughly equal but
there's some imbalances
given the the structure very likely
wow white bomb clouds very likely these
bishops will get traded and
i'll have nike for bishop
so queen b5 looks nice
just hitting the pawn activating the
queen
white might play queen b3 and we can get
a very
positional endgame
if i take on e3 and white takes back
white will have four center pawns
potential for centered pawn cube
and apart from just like memeing i
probably don't want to take on e3
because
it does strengthen white's position
opens that file
but i might have to
[Music]
yeah queen b3
wondering if i can get away with
like takes in just 97.
oh i can also just leave my queen there
it's defended i could play in 87 right
away
let's do that so there's tension between
the bishops and between the queens
i really wouldn't mind if takes takes
and the a-file opens for me
i'm conflicted i kind of want them on
cloud
counseling is also counseling probably
makes more sense to
potentially prepare f5
let's castle we're both getting low on
time i mean this is turning into a blitz
game now
that's nice having a piece here just
blocking the open vial
there is potential for me to get upon
cube too if
i take with i'd take back on b5 with my
a pawn and then
take on c5 with a d-pawn it'd be a
socially distanced pawn cube
wait how long does my hair have to be to
permit
can i not perm like short hair the
scandinavian defense
oh no i wanted to get a haircut
at some point in the future
i i'm neutral when it comes to scandi
because i know some people have very
firm opinions and i don't want to offend
anyone
it's not about opening or is it
it's playable at certain levels
or all levels i don't know
could ask ask that to like john
bartholomew or greg shahadi
a very differing viewpoints
okay let's play f5
so now there's bishop tension queen
tension pawn tension now i just need a
knife
to cut the tension
last two streams i've had two different
knives but
i think they they found their way to the
dishwasher
okay f4
[Music]
pure intuition but looks nice
because if i provoke the trade then my
knight is just way more useful than this
bishop
and there's potential for that file
opening maybe f3 could work in some
tactical lines
oh
i guess i have to take with pawn and
there's a funny line where i take
take and then allow white to have five
center pawns
oh do i do it for the meaning
can i make that work
time is getting low though
wait takes because obviously pawn will
take
it's kind of funny
i don't think it's good for me though
let's do it let's do it i'll try and
make it work
there's no way this is good i have to
take
center pawns at some point
and this is really the only move this
doesn't make sense
okay so i'm giving like
wait what
okay white's still gonna have five
center pawns
i think they're gonna form the secret
the c
shape c for crab
oh it's so funny there's quintuple pawn
potential
okay i also have to try and play this
seriously
man what is this
i'm so bedazzled by all the pawns it's
hard to think straight
i want to play this let's play this move
i want to come over to the king side
if white tries to stop me i'll play this
move and
find my way to enter
this has got to be close to a world
record
i guess this pawn can make its way
eventually
so white can have 600 pawns
oh it's so funny
so i i have a rook tightly material
is bishop for two pawns
it's so rare to see triple pawns next to
double pawns
i'm trying to think objectively here
like who's better
i'm actually not sure because white has
issues with the bishop being sad and the
king being
[Music]
bond clouded
and now i have initiative
but the pawns are a nice um it's nice
kind of decor it's the center
it's a nice centerpiece oh c for center
so many words starting with c
it's going to be unfortunate if i win
this game on time
but okay there's no increment so we're
both going to have to speed things up
tactics of sacking
[Music]
maybe not quite i have this move
not sure what i'm threatening i guess
i'm fighting two pawns
ooh
if i let's take this zero year six
months sub challenge zero minutes six
seconds increment
oh i'll try and understand what that
means
a bit later nice to see you eric
oh nice to see you too ob666
okay let's focus
how to do this in this move
this moves coming
so if this is e7
queen doesn't have too many squares to
go to
let's use my queen side pawns
this is so confusing wait i have this
move
no that doesn't work let's play this
move
what's going on
let's maintain the no i think i should
trade rooks
i don't know though i have a past i have
two past pawns
uh-oh
okay let's play this move da
my time here
ah white has so many pawns
oh no i'm in trouble
or am i i might be
might not be
i'm in trouble
okay at least i can blockade with my
king
no no
it still made oh i didn't think that was
going to happen
but it happened oh what a feeling ending
that's why you always run to the corner
and pray
oh what a game
oh i really didn't think that was gonna
happen
one more game brian oh
ooh okay i have to play one more game
maybe i'm slightly disappointed i didn't
get a chance to give my opponent
quadruple pawns but that was still
i mean i was gonna be sad because
i was expecting to lose but now i'm
pretty happy
i still lost some rating that's okay
hello to youtube
man that game that game started i tried
to
start out instructively and that now i
had to stoop into like meaning
but it was a funny line like takes and
because i sacked
my center stuff for
uh for some potential on the king side
and for this work of art
okay whoa box winning here
yeah i was having trouble evaluating oh
i missed queen e8
queenie it's a hard move to spot
moving all the way backwards to later
move forwards
only winning move too
i guess it has a double threat of queen
h5 and queen e5 look at the
graph of this graph
oh this graph needs to go to the dentist